okay let's go to some notable
discussions from the David Pakman show
subreddit which you can of course find
at david pakman.com slash read it now
boasting nearly sixteen thousand
subscribers from our online radio
television and satellite television
audiences last week i some notable
discussions i want to go over last week
i did a story about the divisions on the
left and there was a faction of the left
that i said you know sometimes I call
this the Leninist left sometimes they
are called tanki's but I find those
terms pejorative I would like to have
some other way to refer to this group
and there's a post on our subreddit
which says David you should call the
Leninist left hankies it's not bad to be
confrontational to ignorant people
tanki's are not just people who espouse
far-left views they are people who hate
the West and like Russia China Iran
North Korea over the US and European
Union these people support Tulsi Gabbard
because of her isolationist stances and
even make false claims that she is
anti-israel okay so listen I I think
that there's a case to be made that the
term may not be an inaccurate one to
call some of these folks tanki's or
Lenin is left my point is I don't think
it's productive because the term is
pejorative and I got a bunch of emails
about this and the consensus was I
should be calling that wing of the left
the revolutionary left or the Marxist
left now Marxist left I'm unsure of
because I don't know that the entire
Leninist left is literally Marxists
they're also not literally not Leninist
so maybe it doesn't matter if the term
literally applies to everyone
revolutionary left may actually be a
good term to non pejoratively describe
that slice of the left let me know what
you think also much follow-up about the
discussion we had earlier this week
about debates with charlie kirk the
right-wing bomb thrower from Turning
Point USA as well as my absence at
politican this user says David needs to
do a public debate
despite the WWE Pro Wrestling vibes I
just watched the political debate
between Kyle kolinsky and Charlie Kirk
and it was frustrating both of them got
applause when they made points
I felt Kyle was correct on substance but
he lost he let Kirk Gish gallop a lot
and could have used more of his time to
make his case even though he did a great
job of demonstrating his consistent
principles and criticizing policies of
both parties he lost his cool way too
often almost to the point of coming
across as whiny I don't know if David
has experience with these kinds of
debates but he's very much in control of
everything when he has guests on who
disagree with him yeah listen I I am
flattered by people saying David you
would have done way better than Kyle in
this scenario I really don't know that
that's the case and I'm not playing fo
humble I mean the those types of
situations can go any number of ways
that when the crowd gets involved when
the moderator plays or doesn't play a
particular role it's not clear to me my
might what I feel very strongly about is
that this is not a format overall in
terms of the timing structure role of
the moderator and role of the audience
that leads to actual productive
discussions counterpoint we are in right
now producing a four interview series
with this guy Aaron Brooke from the ioan
Rand Institute I'm not a Randian as many
of you know I'm not a libertarian or any
other stuff I disagree with your on
Brooke on almost everything but we have
set these up so that they will be for 30
to 40 minute conversations each with a
specific topic no interrupting where we
can actually give our views and argue
against the other's views I think that
that is going to be a format that much
better will serve learning and and
figuring out which ideas reigns supreme
for lack of a better term and a
reference of course to Iron Chef so that
that's where I'll sort of leave it make
sure you are subscribed to the david
pakman show subreddit it's free and more
than 15,000 of you who have already done
it david pakman.com slash re d di t